hi everyone I am takumi machine learning
engineer at Google advanced Solutions
lab
currently a lot of people are talking
about generative Ai and its new
advancement
and as some of you may know Google and
Google Cloud also release so many
generative AI related new products and
features
but in this video series our goal is not
to create a state of art generative AIS
nor to introduce Google Cloud new
products
instead we will explain what kind of
technology is walking behind them
and especially in this video I'm going
to talk about how to actually create a
very simple generative model image
captioning model
by using a Technologies like encoder
decoder attention mechanism and a bit
Transformer
if you're not very familiar with this
concept I recommend checking other
videos talking about them before this
okay so if you're ready let's talk about
image captioning tasks and data set at
first
we're going to use this kind of data set
as you can see there are a lot of pairs
of images and Text data
and our goal is to build and train a
model that can generate these kind of
text captions based on images
and we'll make it happen by building
this kind of model
as you can see it is kind of encoder
decoder model
but in this case encoder and decoder
handle different modality of data which
is image and text
so we pass images to encoder at first
and it extracts information from the
images and create some feature vectors
and then the vectors are passed to the
decoder which actually build captions by
generating was one by one
so the same code apart is easy you can
use any kinds of image backbone like
wristnet efficient net or Vision
Transformer
what we want to do here is to extract
features by using back on the backbones
so call is very simple too
in terms of the code we're going to see
the entire notebook example in the next
video so here let's just focus on some
important lines
as you can see we are using classical
Inception resident V2 here
from Keras applications
but again this can be any image
backbones
so the next part the decoder is a bit
complex
so let's take a look very carefully
so this is the entire architecture of
the decoder
it gets was one by one and makes the
information of bars and images which is
coming from the encoder output
and try to predict the next Wars
so this decoder itself is in kind of
iterative operation so by calling it
again and again also regressively we can
eventually generate text captions
there are so many variations for this
decoder design but here we will
transformer-like architecture although
we still use RNN or Gru
so let's zoom into each component
the first embedding layer creates word
embeddings which was discussed in other
videos
and we are passing it to GRU layer
if you forgot what gru is it's a
variation of recurrent neural network or
you can call RNN
RNN takes inputs and updates its
internal States and generate output
so by passing sequential data like text
Data it keeps the sequential
dependencies from previous inputs like
previous words
the gru output goes to attention layer
which mixes the information of text and
image
in tensorflow Keras we can use
predefined layers in the same way as
other layers
there are multiple implementations but
here we simply use TF Keras layers
attention
but if you want to use more
transformer-like architecture
you can also the pickup TF Keras layers
modes head attention which uses multiple
attention heads
you can simply switch and use it in
almost the same way
inside attention layer it looks like
this
as you may have already seen in another
video about attention mechanism
but unique thing here is it pays
attention to image feature from Text
data
by doing so it can calculate the
attention score by mixing both
information
going back to code you can see this
attention layer takes two inputs
GRE output and encoder output
internally GRE output is used as
attention query and key
and encoder output as value
the last components are add layer and
layer normalization layer
add layer just adds two same shift
vectors
as you can see here Gru output is passed
to a tension layer as we discussed and
to this add layer directly
these two flows are eventually merged in
this other layer
this kind of Architecture is called skip
collection
which has been a very popular deep
neural network design pattern since
resnet
so it is also called residual connection
this skip connection is very useful
especially when you want to design a
very deep neural network
and it is also used in the Transformer
with this now we could build entire
decoder
so we are ready to train the encoder
decoder image captioning model using the
captioning data set
we will see how it works in the next
video
but before moving on to the next one the
I want to explain a bit more about
inference phase where we can actually
generate captions for original images
because this process may look a bit
complex
here you can see three steps and we're
gonna Implement these steps in a custom
inference function
the number one and generate the gru
initial State and create a start token
in training phase tensorflow Keras can
automatically handle GRS state for each
sequence
but in this inference phase since we
designed our own custom function we need
to write a logic to deal with it
explicitly
so at the beginning of each captioning
we explicitly initialize the gru state
with some value
and at the same time remember our
decoder is an auto regressive function
but since we haven't get any water
prediction yet at the beginning of the
inference
we pass start token which is a special
token that means the beginning of a
sentence
number two person input image to the
encoder and extract the feature Vector
as we discussed and number three pass
the vector to
this time decoder and generate a caption
word in the for Loop until it returns n
token or it reads to Max caption links
which is just a hyper parameter
specifying some number like the 64. and
in this for Loop we Define all the
procedures of caption Generation by
calling the decoder also regressively
and token is a special token 2 which
means the end of the sequence
so when our decoder generate this token
we can finish this for Loop
or you can go out of the loop when the
links of the caption reach its some
number Max caption links
let's take a look at the code one by one
in the first step we initialize two
things gr State and start token
in this case Gru state is simply
initialized with zero vectors
and we set start tokens as the first
input Ward for the decoder
in terms of the war to index function
used here I'm going to explain in the
next video
but basically it's just tokenized the
words to War token which is the standard
text pre-processing technique
in the next step we pre-process the
input image a bit and pass it to the
encoder we train
in term result the image pre-processing
it reasons the code jpeg in the first
line
and it resize it from any arbitrary
resolutions to specific resolution
and it changes the scale from 0 to 255
to 0 to 1 in the third line
and the last phase decoder for Loop
it is a bit complex so I will explain in
the next video more in detail with the
actual code
but the main thing here is to call the
decoder by passing three things
Decor inputs means decoder input which
should have a War token predicted in the
previous iteration
and as we talked if it is the first
iteration this would be the start token
jirio state is the current GRE State we
discussed and please note that the
decoder or output the updated GRS state
and last but not least features
this is the image feature we extracted
with the encoder
bypassing them we can get the actual
next word prediction
this is a very simple text generation
model from images
but this kind of iteration is very
similar even in very large language
generation models like Google bard
they basically predict the next word
also regressively in this way one by one
based on some information and land
knowledge which is embedded in a huge
number of parameters
in the next video I will walk you
through the entire notebook
and then we will check what kind of
captions this model can generate
thank you so much for watching and see
you in the next video